thank you Sam so first of all it's
really an honor to be here tonight I
made a mistake when I when I said yeah
sure I would do this and I said hey
could you send me some example are some
really great talks you've had in your
past and so they did of course and I
sent me Melinda Gates and Bill Gross in
reed hoffman i almost called said you've
got the wrong person right but thank you
so much i'm honored to be here in the
and the company of your past speakers so
i really do appreciate that so what I
thought I'd do tonight is just walk you
through what inspired us to launch
canvas ventures I was asked to give you
a little bit about my background and how
I came in to venture it's it's not a
linear path as you will see and then I'd
love to talk to you a little bit about
you know canvas and what we look for in
both entrepreneurs and companies and
then I was asked to leave you with some
advice so what I would have liked to
know when I was in my 20s had I listened
and that really wasn't that long ago
either so so I'm not I'm not that old I
promise so so first of all you know one
thing to keep in mind is through the
talk is I never planned on getting
adventure it was not something when I
was in your shoes that I thought hey
I'll be a venture capitalist someday it
really was through a series of very
lucky events i would say through some
really amazing mentors that i had in my
past and and through just keeping an
open mind and taking advantage of
opportunities as they came as they came
my way so first of all a little bit
about my background so i grew up in
rural missouri I grew up farming pretty
much my cut my my parents didn't go to
college they couldn't offer me really
much advice on what classes to take or
that I should be an engineer or not and
my dad didn't even really know what to
do with a girl right he had five
brothers so he grew up on a farm with
the six boys and I was the first one on
the scene right so what happened so at
the age of five I learned how to play
poker in cards right that was early math
skills ah no joke and you know I learned
how to hunt how to fish how to ride
horses had I can do all that stuff I
could i and and my toys were literally
you know most remote control cars and
race track
X and robotics kids which I always loved
I thought that was great I thought the
boys toys were much cooler anyway but it
really set me up well for life today so
when people say hey what's it like to
work with a bunch of guys and like I
just don't know anything different right
so so it all works ok and and when you
look at those roots people always campy
especially people that I know from back
in my early career they said how did you
end up an adventure you know what
happened and I never really thought
about it too much until they asked me to
come here tonight and and it was really
interesting because I think there are
really three things it might not seem
obvious that that helped me get here
tonight and and the first one was that
help maybe sort of Who I am today the
first ones my parents actually went
bankrupt and the 80s farming crisis and
it was catastrophic as you can imagine
so you know from a very young kid having
that happen but had that not happened I
never would be here tonight because that
little town I grew up in the highest
level math class that was possible for
any kid that grew up in that town was a
very rudimentary trigonometry class and
there just isn't a way for a kid to come
out of that background and possibly
think about being an engineer right so
because that happened we moved to a town
with a much better educational system
and I was able to take calculus and
everything in high school but I look
back and it's really informative for me
today because you know startups and life
and everything you mean it doesn't go
necessarily according to plan a really
ever right but oftentimes there's a kind
of a meaning for things or a reason that
things happen and so what has taught me
to do and to really coach others to do
is okay well that didn't work who cares
i put it aside right let's look for Plan
B and Plan B could even be better and
often times it is so it's given me a ton
of perspective the other thing that
helped me a lot and I look back and I
come you know what else really mattered
and those were gifted programs and I'm
sure looking at this audience I'd love
to see hands how many here were a part
of like a gifted program from like third
grade through like eighth grade yeah
okay so those don't exist anymore right
and at least in California in the rest
of the country they still do but you
know when you're looking at a kid from a
relatively poor economic
ground who doesn't have mentors and role
models to show them hey look what you
can do with your life those programs for
me were very important dry program
computers in third grade for example we
took biochemistry and debate in sixth
grade and I had people around me saying
hey you can and should do these things
and it's funny when I have sat down and
talked to a number of other you know
tech luminaries in the valley who come
from similar backgrounds than me that is
a common denominator of almost everyone
I know and I think it's absolutely
tragic that that we don't have them
today and children that are you know
more and more affluent or whatever I
mean my kids they can go to nueva they
can do these things but if you're not
sort of from that background I think
it's really unfortunate that they don't
exist anymore in California and the
third thing that I thought of and it
made me want to go back in contact some
people was moment my mentor so those
people in your life that really had no
obligation right to help you but they
did for some reason and you should
always thank those people if you can
write and so I looked back and there was
this pivotal time in high school and
believe it or not I was trying to choose
between being an art major and an
engineer so I'm and you laugh I'm very
split right and it was sort of a 50-50
split on the artistic and the
engineering side and I had this great
physics professor mr. bath and he knew
me knew my background and he just pulled
me aside one day and he's like Rebecca
I'm just let me just tell you how this
is going to go down right he said you
can go to art school and you can be an
artist it is like I'm sure you're going
to be a phenomenal artist he goes but
artists make no money until they're dead
they're not famous and so they're dead
and he goes or you know what you could
do is you could be an engineer and guess
what if you're an engineer you can be a
doctor a lawyer CEO physicist a Salesman
a teacher he just went on and on and on
and on he's like oh and by the way you
could also be an artist and somebody may
actually pay you to go to engineering
school and nobody's going to pay you to
go to art school and so I took mr. baths
advice and I wouldn't become an engineer
and I'm really I'm lucky that he he did
pull me aside and he took the time to
what to give that advice
to me so I went to engineering school at
the University of Missouri which has
some unfortunate press around it at this
point in time I'm sorry to say but my
initial plan was to go back and get a
PhD and I worked at a in cancer research
at a nuclear reactor on campus and I
really enjoyed that work and what I
enjoyed more than anything else which
has a lot to do with bench from now I
guess is I would bounce around to all
the other labs in the nuclear reactor
and we had some really cool stuff we had
the space crystals we had the o-rings we
had super magnets we had semiconductors
we had all that that kind of work and it
was just really fascinating they
constantly learn about you know what was
going on and and I enjoyed that and the
thought of spending the next five to
seven years which to me seemed like a
lifetime at that point in my life just
doing one thing and was sort of beyond
what I could what I could comprehend
right so instead I went to work at
Procter & Gamble and that seems
surprising to a lot of people right i
went into product I did international
work so new products and new markets
around the world and and and people are
confused by this but at P&G and other
companies like that unlike in Silicon
Valley largely they look to product and
marketing people that have a very solid
technical background so usually those
are chemical engineers those I mean I
think eighty percent of the people I
worked with and product and marketing or
camis because you're expected to build
models a predicted consumer you know
predicted consumer response and you're
expected to know her your way around
stats and design experiments and things
like that so I had a great experience
there when I hire people today for
companies I still look for that in any
kind of marketing or product position
and those by far have been the best
marketing hires we've had or people with
that technical background so at this
point in time the dot-com boom was
happening right this was probably the
98th time frame I would say and it was a
really crazy time in the Bay Area in San
Francisco in general it looked then sort
of like it does now but it rained
every single day for what three months
on end I think every single day and and
it was interesting when you went to look
for apartments you think it's bad now
but we had you know no craigslist no
amazon no i phone you literally would go
and pay somebody at Retta net sixty
dollars for a list of apartments and and
good luck right so so I did that and I
worked at a company called next card now
how many of you all have heard about
next card very few yeah so so next card
I was employed 30 I was a product person
it next card which is over a lot of vc's
come from they come from the product
sort of background and training and that
next card was backed by a lot of firms
you well first of all next card was the
first online credit card company it was
a very first company to allow you to go
online and apply for a credit card and
get it in real time we actually had the
patent for real-time approval of credit
online which would be a very valuable
patent today I think some patent troll
and Texas owns it or something at this
point in time and and so we were backed
by firms I'm sure everyone's heard of
here kleiner perkins in sequoia and
trinity and brentwood which is now red
point and among others and we grew from
thirty people to 1,300 people we went
public we were one of the top online
advertisers we were usually at number
three in terms of the number of
impressions we served online the only
company is ahead of us were Yahoo and
Microsoft in any given month typically
and we had to build all that from
scratch there was no Google right so I'm
really dating myself aren't I tom and so
we had to actually build the
infrastructure to go and run as on
hundreds and thousands of different
sites out there meaning building our own
affiliate platform and ad tracking
system in the whole bit and so that
company was a pretty formidable company
and and we lost ninety-eight percent of
our value in one day on the public
market so a couple of a couple of
learnings from this right
at one when you can take some money off
the table you should do it right please
learn from my mistake and and it's just
it's like when you play poker right you
go to the table when you're up you take
some money off of the table and you play
with your winnings it's a very good rule
in life and so you know we often
encourage our entrepreneurs and people
that you know and we're in a company
just know when you're at a certain point
and you're happy don't be greedy take
some money off the table be happy and
then and then continue to continue to go
forward I think it's a very good rule of
life in general and the second thing I
learned is I did have a chance to talk
to some VCS after you know after this
happened and I said wow what happened
and I could tell you i mean we could
spend the whole hour just talking about
what went wrong at that company right
there's a case study the case study is
totally wrong by the way so don't read
that but they uniformly said this they
said listen when the company had 30
people there were four amazing senior
managers right but when the company had
1,300 people and it was a public company
it was the same for senior managers and
so I think what you take from this and
what I tried in part on the company's I
bath is that you have to constantly
evolve your management team and your
employee base people who are rock stars
and you couldn't build the company with
adam its series a might not be there
maybe see players when you get to de
enough right there are some people that
will make it all the way those people I
have seen it they work really really
really really hard to make it all the
way right they get coaches they get
advice they do 360s they are constantly
work very hard it's not like you know
you can make that journey on your own I
mean I tell my cos I'm even Steve Jobs
had a coach for God's sake and so so
people that make it all the way look for
those types of resources but it's very
rare and so you really have to
constantly know ask yourself you know
where you are and if you're doing enough
to make that transition and then
constantly you know refresh the team and
really look to see if you have the best
players on the field
so after I left next card I actually
started my own company it was a
marketing consultant company and I had
some grave is basically targeted at
financial services i had providian and
which again how many of you have heard
of providian that was another one right
I had a capital one and Experian his
clients and that was great I had a
really fun time and I learned things
they are too I learned I loved working
for myself that was really fun I loved
employing people I love working with um
senior management of different companies
and I also learned that consulting
services types of firms just don't scale
right they they could be very profitable
but beyond a certain point they don't
scale and they're really hard to grow
very large so so at that point in my
life I i decided i needed a sabbatical
if I was ever going back to school it
was now and I yes school was my
sabbatical which people think it's crazy
but for me it was really fun right when
I did undergraduate I work three jobs i
was at the nuclear reactor i taught
football players chemistry which was
really interesting and then i also
worked at restaurants and did things
like that so the fact i could now just
go back to school and go to school was a
huge treat for me and so I did that and
the idea when I went back to school was
to start a company to meet other
founders and start a company and also to
start a family and and so that's really
what I spent my time doing I actually
did I had a baby when I was in school so
that the second year of law school I had
a baby two days after my last final and
law school she was sort of the class
mascot from that she just came to class
she was great so that that was a little
bit insane but it all worked out well
and and so while i was at Berkeley I
really focus on two things I did IP
intellectual property law one of the
companies I worked on was in patent
pooling and then I also focused on
entrepreneurship and ran the business
plan competition when i was there i
think it's now called launch and that's
again the whole idea was to go back to
school and start a company with some
other people and that's actually how I
met Gary little Gary little is a partner
for
I think Tom's known him for years and
and my job was literally to just get
Gary to where he was supposed to be sort
of like me tonight right make sure he
was fed an on-stage on time and that was
it and so so he started talking to me
and we were comparing notes and we kind
of knew some of the same people right
and at the end Gary says you know we've
never hired a summer associate before
but you know would you be interested and
I said absolutely not I said you know I
have a three month old right now I'm
starting to company there's just no way
and I personally never saw myself as a
VC I mean for me all the feces I knew
were like white guys from Harvard and
Stanford right so so why would I sign up
for that and about that time I had this
bad pain in the back of my leg and my
friend Kevin it just kicked me as hard
as he could and immediately when Gary
walked up Kevin pulls me aside and he
says Rebecca what what are you thinking
that man is the nicest man in Silicon
Valley he's phenomenal and Morgenthaler
is such a great firm and I'd be honored
to have that position and what are you
doing and so I thank God for Kevin so I
walked up after after the panel was over
and I apologized profusely and I said if
you'll still talk to me you have to
understand I haven't slept I have a
three-month-old at home I wasn't
supposed to be here tonight and so he
said of course and so I emailed my
resume n I heard nothing for three
months right and you have to understand
VCS are really pretty disorganized
people actually it's not uncommon that
that happens in our industry and an
email is more like a Twitter stream I
think that anything else for us so so
three months later I i went in and then
he had a day by the time I left that
interview they said hey just come on as
a summer I worked three days a week that
summer I loved it and then continued on
through my last year of school doing a
day or two a week and it was really
amazing it was the first time in my life
where I felt like I was getting paid for
what I was just kind of doing anyway
which was was was great and I learned a
couple things they're also i learned
just to be open for opportunities right
i think so many of us have this like
tunnel vision just hey plan a here's
where I'm going right
and you miss half of this story and so
just letting yourself be open and
receptive to things that just happen to
come your ways for that natural
serendipity is really important and then
the other thing I learned is if you see
your friend just making a really stupid
mistake please intervene right always
always take that upon yourself to do
that so so I started I did take the bar
and I graduate it i took passed it thank
God and I came to work in the fall of
2008 and again I had no plan to be there
for very long they think I was ass and
senior associate or something my plan
was simply to get them to fund one of
the business ideas I was working on and
I would constantly pitch Gary on
different ideas or to start a comfort to
find a company to to join and and how
many of you remember what the fall of
2008 look like I was fun yeah souleiman
crash the financial credit markets they
absolutely froze and practically every
publication you could read an article
about venture capital being dead we
actually had a speaker coming to
Berkeley who proclaimed that the angel
investing was never never coming back
right and you know all my friends who
had the four hundred thousand dollar
your banking jobs are now out of work
and I think thirty percent of all the
law firm offers got pulled right so very
different than we're looking at today
but Morgenthaler had just closed a 400
million dollar fund and I was like a kid
in a candy store right because we had
this fund and we had there were still
great entrepreneurs out there and and
for me I'm more of a contrarian I guess
so i thought it was a really great time
to be in venture and i even had at an
event where we invited on dick cram like
who founded nea and read dentist who
founded i vp and then David Morgenthaler
to come and talk to everyone who wasn't
yet a partner because it was a pretty
stressful time in the industry right and
and they were hilarious they went
through the cycle after cycle after
cycle you know every 10 to 15 years
venture capital dying and
it was it was it was a great event and
that and from that I took away a few
things yes market cycle and sue that
venture won't ever ever be dead I mean I
think it will go through its cycles it
will change and it will morph but
they're always going to be people with
crazy ideas that no one's going to
believe will work and will work that
needs somebody to believe in them and to
provide to provide financing so so then
lending club so let's just move on to
lending club lending club was the very
first deal that I did believe it or not
so this is a little bit of luck right a
lot of luck and that we saw them in q1
of 09 and again we just thought the
timing for this kind of opportunity was
perfect we had had a thesis about the
dinner disintermediation of banking that
applied all the way since you next card
the way I had been looking in the space
and here is a company when the credit
markets were frozen that was loaning to
a prime section of borrowers so people
who are highly credit worthy and we
believe that even in the worst economic
cycle there was a pocket of these prime
borrowers that could be loaned to and
that lending club had done everything
today in the right way they had focused
on the upper end of the credit market
the prime credit market they had pretty
good underwriting they had cooperated
with regulators which is very very
important for a number of these types of
industries that are really having to
figure out their way through some pretty
massive regulation and and the CEO had
had a really huge vision to be you know
to be this the world's largest market
place for lending and more isn't the
most important thing for me is I felt
like they had three to five years before
the banks could react like the banks
would just be frozen for the next three
to five years so so the thing that
happened there which was really
instrumental was I was a principal right
so we presented the term sheet to
Renault the CEO and and I didn't know it
was going to happen i had actually hoped
i could get a you know board observer
seat and i would learn a lot and we
would see but we're now asked for me to
be on the board which is really unusual
and I think the more unusual thing about
that is my partner
a little said of course right and of
course she will be and not only that but
he took the board observer seat to coach
me to to be a good board member and
that's a big transition it's a very
different thing from being an operator
or a consultant to going onto a board
and so here I had this VC who has been
doing it for what 10 12 years at least
at the time come on the board and coach
me and say okay Rebecca will when you
said this maybe it would have been
better to have set it outside the board
meeting or maybe think about this in a
different way and and I was really lucky
that he took that time with me to make
that happen so in terms of in terms of
lending club I was on the board there
from from q1 of 09 to just a couple
months ago right and it was funny when I
looked back when I rolled off the board
I sentra know my initial thesis of
investing and when we had come on the
board there has done the investment
there were 25 people in the company
they'd only done 20 million dollars of
origination to that point in time I
think they had about four hundred
thousand dollars of revenue and they
actually went public a year ago
yesterday and at that point in time they
were as Tom had said that the fourth the
largest tech IPO of last year in the US
and the fourth largest sense since accom
with only Google a Facebook and Twitter
being larger so it was really phenomenal
and actually have gotten the opportunity
to be on that on the board with people
like John Mack who's now got involved in
future advisor another one of our
companies and mary meeker and Larry
Summers was really a spectacular
experience so so there is definitely
some some luck involved in an adventure
probably more than a little so with that
I'd like to transition to canvas and
what inspired us to create a brand new
firm out there so when it came time to
raise our next fund we actually you know
kind of scratch for your next fund
Morgenthaler we looked at it and instead
we decided to spin out and do an
entirely new firm and name that Candice
ventures and the idea about canvas is
really what kind of firm would we want
to create if we could do it from scratch
and what kind of firm would it not
really be attracted to and canvas itself
is all about creating the entrepreneurs
vision on a blank slate or canvas and
maybe a little bit of an odd back to my
desire to be an artist at some point in
my life and so so today you know canvas
includes you have Gary little and myself
we have two additional partners have
joined paul schou who was a partner in
EA for about 10 years who's just a
terrific terrific guy did a company
called house which is one of my very
favorite companies out there and then
ben nourison and then was a seed
investor we had known been for a long
time he was an early investor in two of
my companies both check and lending club
and then he's in a lot of other
companies that I'm sure you all know
including benefits and drop cam and
cabbage and his hit rate is just really
phenomenal so at the four of us are now
are now canvas we've had some really
early recognition which works excuse me
excited about we were named by the the
Forbes Midas list is one of the top bc
firms to watch and I was lucky enough to
be put on the minus list at 23 so you
ask yourself there's a lot of venture
firms out there what makes us different
right why why us so there are a few
things that we think are important one
is we are all operators and
entrepreneurs every one of us has has
built a company Ben's taken a company
public Paul sold a company and
insecurity before he started at any a or
you know been a major operator at at a
large company or both actually and so so
we think that's important because what
I've learned over the course of my time
and venture is it's only about
twenty-five percent picking the right
company that's I think that's probably
the right especially the series a and B
it gets more of as a picking kind of
maneuver as you get later stage it's 75%
building I'm fixing right and so if
you're doing that and it's early stage
and you need help building and fixing my
thought is you really want somebody who
has done it before who has seen has seen
the PlayBook before and can really help
you along the way so for us that was
really important the other thing is
we're very thesis driven investors
everything
one of us and naturally so and so even
though you know before we were working
together it was funny that was how we
all approach the problem and so what
that means is it doesn't mean that we
sit you know and think about things and
participate it means that we look for
big market trends so you know the
financial markets freezing or you know
the HITECH Act rolling and or the
Affordable Care Act or the I was some
big macro trend and then we look where
we think the the big companies can be
built and we at we map that space we map
it pretty intently and very deeply and
then we pick one company in that space
so and with just FinTech we looked at
you know the lending space and that was
lending club we looked at mobile wallet
that was checked which sold to intuit we
looked at financing and the evolution of
investing and that was future advisor
which was recently purchased by
blackrock so that we are very thesis
driven the areas that we really like to
look deeply in and blue and will
continue to our financial services and
healthcare IT a market places we love
marketplaces mobile in general and as my
partner Ben will tell you his that his
favorite thesis was to be looking for
the next thesis so we do also get to do
some quick dives into things like at
agricultural technology and drones and
things like that to see where where that
next thesis maybe and and we all every
single one of us has at least 1 billion
dollar company under US and Gary little
actually as three so we've seen the
evolution to the early-stage nascent
part of a company all the way through to
a growth stage company or a public
company and that's really important
because the problems are different at
every single level as you go so where do
we focus we focus on Series A and B so
what that means is this is where you
have you know you're starting to get a
product market fit the dogs reading the
dog food and now you need to scale you
need to grow a team it's probably a
skeletal team at best at that point in
time you need your really you might have
gotten a couple of the marketing
channels figured out just to prove the
concept works but you need things to
scale and you're perhaps building to
your sales force so that that's really
where we come in a series a and B
usually five to ten million and
an initial round and and we always take
a board seat in terms of what we look
for I mean this this is tough you mean
some people you know of course it's a
big market opportunity right and but
it's hard to actually see sometimes it
will be a big market and so I was once
it was one person had put to me one time
this is what I will always sticks in my
head is we have to believe if the stars
lined up perfectly and you had a
straight a straight shot that the
company could be a billion dollar
company plus now maybe a billion dollars
doesn't seem like a lot right now but it
wasn't that long ago when 180 million
was them was the biggest exit we had all
year right so it has to be able to be I
would say a sustainable public company
for us to get involved now there are a
lot of businesses out there that aren't
there was a lot of businesses that we
talked to every day or startups that you
know can sell for 10 or 100 or maybe a
couple hundred million but if we really
believe that's the endpoint outcome for
a company that that's not where we would
jump in we really have to have to see
that it could be a during public company
and I think you know I there's a quote
my mind from Ray rothrock that always
that all I always think of and that is
you know the vote the biggest companies
they ever have funded where where
markets moved over a company right where
there wasn't really an addressable tam
at that point in time but then started
moving and all of a sudden the market
just sort of intercepted the company and
those are the hardest ones see and those
are usually the biggest winners in terms
of what type of people we look for of
course we look for somebody who's smart
and who's focused but we look for
something else we look for somebody who
has something to prove so you know
somebody who has a chip on their
shoulder so to speak that really like
the company is a part of them right and
this is what really separates the
founder from the CEO right somebody who
is a founder like that company is a part
of them and they will they will do
whatever it takes so when plan a doesn't
work they're going to work on plan b c
and d right and as those are the kind of
people that are just incredibly driven
and won't stop and they will absolutely
figure it out i once i had a friend
that was he was he was he was exactly
this person and he created a pretty
interesting company i said i would give
this guy a million dollars if he was
hoeing potatoes right because he just
has so much to prove and he will
absolutely figure it out and then why do
we choose the deals we choose so so this
is hard right and it was funny because i
don't know how many of you guys know
Kevin Ryan but Kevin did double-click
and guilt and mongodb and business
insider and done a couple others as well
as hit rates phenomenal and I thought of
all people he would be able to at class
and I said why do you work with all
these different VCS and your company's
why don't you just have sort of one set
and you looked at me funny and you said
you know what he goes it it's impossible
for me to tell what will make a VC fall
in love with the deal right and I think
if you ask the VC themselves they were
really honest they would tell you the
same thing right and it's one of those
you know it when you see it kind of
things and and for me it's always the
question I asked myself if I wasn't
adventure what I want to work at this
company what I want to work with this
team is this the job I would take for
the next five to ten years and am i
waking up thinking about it the next day
and if I am that that's when I that's
when i'll do the deal so that's a little
bit about you know what we look for of
course we love marketplaces and network
effects and anything that can have a
moat around the company but they're
often just some higher-level things than
that that I think really drive the
investment decision at the end of the
day so I have ten minutes left they
asked me to give you some advice and
things that I wish I would have known
when I was 20 and maybe somebody told me
but I'd probably didn't listen very well
though I'm happy to offer a little bit
of advice one thing is just you know
life happens and often things that may
seem like the most tragic and dismal at
that point in time are actually the
catalyst for something even better and
what makes it a catastrophe or something
you know a catalyst is really your
attitude towards it and how you see the
next day and so really you know really
always be looking ahead and think about
you know well maybe this just created an
opportunity right for me to at
do something different the other thing
is you know you're really I don't need
to tell you this we all know you're
really fortunate to be here like none of
us would be here today if it weren't for
some phenomenal mentors or people in our
lives that helped us along the way and
made that possible and and that we owe
it to people to to do something in
return and to help others that were very
similar to us in those situations so in
big in small ways so one of the
initiatives I was lucky to be invited to
be a part of this EIG the economic
innovation group in a suit group is like
ron conway and sean parker and others
that are really looking at how do we
create technology and innovation
opportunities in the midwest right or in
distressed communities in general
because you know a recovery happened but
it sort of missed the entire middle of
the united states right and so I think
those are really interesting
opportunities as you're looking for for
I mean just ways to get involved and
just really opportunities in general
I've always wondered why offshore
doesn't just mean you know somewhere
back and in the Midwest and actually
there are a few companies that are
exactly starting to do that and my
favorite piece of fundraising advice
I'll do that and then one last piece of
advice and I'm done favorite piece of
fundraising advice comes from Jeff
tagged me who was a GSB actually he was
a founder of Hippocrates and then he's
my CEO and founder at docs Timothy which
is the the largest doctor network it's
linkedin for doctors they have about
two-thirds of all doctors in the US on
the platform today and he always says
when you want advice ask for money and
when you want money ask for advice and
that's always true if you if you call
anybody you know like hey I need to
raise around your they're not going to
talk to you but if you want advice most
people will take that meeting right so
so if you're raising money always ask
for advice and then then in regard to
life in general i'll just leave you with
this i do a lot of talking to you know
like women and startups and things like
that and I and I always tell them this
and that it just applies to everyone
though is do you know really do what you
would do if you had absolutely no chance
to fail right so typically you know
it's cliche what you what you know the
things you regret in life or what you
didn't do so what I always tell my
founders you know when they're when
they're thinking about well do i do x or
do i do why i said ok well let's just
pretend that you had no chance to fail
and then tell me what it is you would do
and then let's just do that right
because because you can always figure
out plan b and c md later right but what
you're going to regret is that thing
that you really wanted to do that you
talked yourself out of so that is Maya
that's my departing piece of advice so
with that I would like to turn it to
questions and I think I'm six minutes
ahead of schedule so thank you I choose
yeah oh wow does anyone have questions I
guess the red is your very life for the
things you didn't do what's the deal
that you didn't do to your breath the
most uber yeah so he asked me if this is
a funny story so he asked me if the
things I did in life for things I didn't
do what deal did I not do you guys are
tough that I regret the most so I me and
so here's funny I mean every VC their
anti portfolio is phenomenally better
than their portfolio right at everyone
and actually bessemer used to have their
anti portfolio on their website I don't
they do so I haven't seen their website
in a little bit it's really great and
and everyone has these stories and
because the thing is is that you know
move the companies that i funded I mean
Lending Club probably talked to half of
the valley right as to practice Fusion
as a doc simha d I mean most
entrepreneurs will tell you it was
impossible for them to raise money until
it wasn't right and so so everyone has
these stories and probably half of
Silicon Valley has an uber story but
literally I had called Travis clinic and
he he was in cary oh and i was in
practice fusion and our founders had an
issue so he was in the office and he'd
been a really prolific you know angel
investor he'd done red swoosh she's a
his red spruce story is really
phenomenal and he's like and I was just
kind of going through his Angela
portfolio which is impressive and I said
you know this is company
uber that I found it and I'm thinking
about maybe taking the ce o-- role and
you should look at it and I'm like no no
I don't think so I've seen the or three
or four companies like that and I just I
just didn't get it right and and so and
so and so fast forward I've got my
little guy Zane who's who's five and we
go to the city for the day and he's
melting down and and I and he's just
he's losing his mind I'm like okay I
need to get him out of here forget the
trolley and so I called uber and I'm
like look and I show him he's like wow
right and and I sent that I said the
video clip off and he goes and so he's
just so enamored and he gets in the car
and he closes the door and we get home
later and were at dinner and he looks
left news like mommy when I grow up I'm
going to make a lot of money so I can go
out to eat dinner every night and uber
will take me everywhere and I was like
wow what a rockstar I would have been
identify room at that one definitely
okay who else yes a 98-percent
evaluation loss and one day how did you
deal with that personally okay so uh it
wasn't easy and so there's a longer part
to that story I was actually in France
so I makes it even more interesting
right so I had I'd worked like Tyrus Lee
for four years I mean it was a crazy
this was back before you had cloud
computing like you balance the service
at midnight and hope that you've got the
thing going before the East Coast woke
up so it was a really a crazy four year
experience and so I had decided to leave
and take a little sabbatical and go to
this equestrian school in France which
was like boot camp so I was like riding
five horses a day including racehorses
and clingy installs and doing crazy
stuff and so I got a phone call while I
was I while I was in the middle of
nowhere in France that that had happened
and I remember my husband that told me
and I was like wow and I said okay and I
said tell you what I said I can't just I
couldn't digest it at that point in time
and I'm like you know what let me just
think about this for why don't we just
talk into davis right and it's just
something that I mean we had never were
pretty conservative so
we had like it was paper right we had
the thought about it but it was that it
was really it was it was yeah I was
pretty young actually so what and it
wasn't that much money for us right
because i was i was pretty junior at the
time um but yeah it was a it's
definitely has shaped sort of you know a
lot of how we think about things so and
i'm not i mean there are a lot of people
at that time that had margin loans so
for us it was not that traumatic we we
saw a lot of people that you know they
were talked into doubling and tripling
down and taking margin loans and doing
all kinds of crazy stuff and those
people it was it was pretty bad for
actually so yeah do you have sit in own
habits or some sort of mindset that you
would say you had before when you were
younger that brought you to where you
are now or then help me to success
clavis reminds that you know i think the
only habit of is always just wanting to
learn more and just very curious and
love to travel and I just I always love
to learn about people's ideas right and
about science and technology and that
that really I mean it makes it to where
I love the job I do right it's just kind
of a natural fit and I think you're
really lucky when you can do what you
love but mother habit or mindset was
just I was always very curious about
what and some people might call that a
TD I don't know but it could be
classified that way potentially but I
was always very curious about things
that were out there and wanted to learn
about about technology and science stuff
so that was good yes I also like to
gamble too so that was probably yeah
yeah yes sobres be seized with operating
background what do you think they can
offer that Jenna DC which is are always
background Hoggart founders yeah
she has a VC with operating background
versus not now there are they're very
good bc's out there amazing ones that
have no operating background right and
their RVs and it cuts both ways like
sometimes Avicii is really about pattern
matching right and about seeing a lot of
things happen time and time again so so
i think i think the operating background
what that what that gets you is somebody
who has seen it and been in your shoes
before that can sort of help you figure
you're out you know the next few steps
right and and I think that that's what
somebody who's been an operator can
really do for you Vic and add that purse
they have perspective right and and
these things don't have it sometimes
could just be a little too cavalier
right they're like oh well just you XO
Mike well of course I would do X if X
was easy but it's not right and here's
the 10 other things I have to happen
before X can happen and so with the
operating background I think you have
that perspective basically yes so last
week we had this Scott cook that he said
that he went when you found it into it
he went to raise money and he talked to
34 investors and was rejected yes but
then the story in a very well for him
because he's a billionaire I without so
bootstrapping the company so I guess a
question for you would be when will you
tell a CEO to convince him or her to go
the VC route instead of trying to boost
rap and grow the company yeah i mean i
think i think it's it oh yeah i'm so
sorry so he asked so Scott cook had
talked to sort of 30 40 vc's it said no
and then he bootstrapped the company
right and it worked out quite well for
him and his question was what would you
tell somebody would you tell somebody to
bootstrap or two to raise money there
been a lot of people that I said God why
would you raise venture money it's just
going to screw it all up right i mean
i've had a lot of people come in that
have interesting businesses right and
they're profitable but they think they
want to raise venture and i look at this
and like wow that's going to throw off
you know some pretty significant cash
pretty quickly but it's not going to be
venture scalable and if you sign up for
you know venture money there's a
different expectation for you right
there is an expectation that instead of
growing like this you're going to grow
like this at some point in time and
there is an exit event as well I mean
they're one of my favorite companies in
the world is epic how many of you guys
know i mean the healthcare yeah epic is
amazing and i think recently they've
taken some money but that company is
like eighty percent owned by one person
right and that's a pretty phenomenal
company so so there are other ways
besides venture but really venture is
where you see there's an opportunity and
you need the capital to realize it
scale fast enough to get there that's
kind of how I think about whether you
take whether you take venture money or
not yes in the back question in regards
to coaches um besides finding someone
who has done or gone through the process
and you're trying to do like someone
who's gone through all the rounds of
funding to the point of successfully
having a multi-billion dollar company
what are things to look for when you're
looking for coach you know what are what
are you look for when you look what do
you look for when you look for a coach
you know it's interesting I think
coaches are a very personal thing and
and so what I mean I think it's so
personal it's hard to answer that my
suggestion is you don't just meet one
you meet half a dozen and then and you
then you start figuring out where the
chemistry is right and you know where
their focus is right because somebody
who works really well for one CEO it
doesn't work at all for somebody else
and so you know I like to suggest that
people actually got a coach when I saw
some of the mat amazing work some of
these coaches had and when the CEOs came
back and said wow this person really
helped me with it you know x y&z that
well I should try this too and it really
helped me as well because here's
somebody without a dog in the fight
right that can can give you some really
constructive feedback their only goal is
that you become a better you know person
and whatever it is you're doing right
and they're going to give you that
feedback and they don't have an agenda
and so it's I think what you have to do
is have a chemistry where you trust that
person and that you actually respect
what they're going to tell you and that
just comes from really meeting a bunch
of them and figuring out where that fit
might be the best I would say are there
questions yes about bold and outrageous
ideas yet to find a principle market yes
now these ideas typically become the
biggest winners get executed right so i
was wondering personally are there any
server six that you use to kind of
recognize and identify these ideas at
the idea well i mean when somebody
really smart sits in front of me and
they
tell me something that I just think
sounds insane I think twice right so
I've learned that over over the course
of time so I don't know if there's any
heuristics but but whenever I always pay
attention to things that are trying to
show that disprove a belief i have right
so in other words if I have a sort of
set thinking and in a certain market
vertical or something and then somebody
comes and shows me that what I believe
is my set of truths to be wrong that's
when I really pay attention right when I
want to so for example this is a small
example of a practice Fusion and we
thought Super Bowl acquiring doctor's
office this is going to be a feat on the
street sort of trench warfare effort
they figured out how to do it online
right and that that really made me wake
up like wow you know how does that work
and they and then we talked that model
so so a lot of times it is when I mean
you kind of have a belief system you've
seen a lot it's when somebody shows you
something that just surprises you right
and that that's when you learn to really
pay attention yeah I hope that answered
your question yes so VC firms of
traditionally sisters investee companies
by helping with great talent being full
partners to the management team do you
see the role of VC evolving and if so
what is the future is competing I mean I
I think that will remain in terms of
what VC funds do you know and and for us
we only do a deal or two a year per
partner right so we do a lot of recruit
I mean if you ask for now at London club
my the main thing i did it was recruit
you know and help him higher at every
point in the company and I enjoy that a
lot we helped a lot with PR we helped a
lot of marketing with strategy but with
our firm its us that does that right and
then we have we also have a marketing
partner you know with other firms
they've built out whole resources for
that and so it really depends on the
entrepreneur in terms of you know the
fit I think both models work and I just
think it depends on I want the
entrepreneurs looking for and where you
want to get that that
oh yes do you see venture capitalists as
we're going into more global economy you
see them looking to other regions of the
world and especially where would you be
looking yeah we you did we we have
stayed very focused on the west coast I
think David Morgenthaler put it well
don't fly over good deals to look at
good deals right but there have been
really big successes in China and India
now is it is a big an area of focus
Europe there's a lot of things going on
in Europe that have you know there's
start there they may come over this
direction I actually saw a zero believe
it or not when I was in New Zealand I
walked into it I was in New Zealand for
I was looking at some incubators there
and that and walked into a zero board
meeting before you know found respond or
had put any money into it and it was a
very interesting company but that's
based in New Zealand and then they came
over here right so there are a lot of
things that are like that app Annie
started in Hong Kong i believe and came
came to the US so so you are seeing
venture firms sort of expand globally I
think two approaches one is to invest in
the company that's a Chinese company in
China right the other one is to look for
companies and other markets that may
then want to expand into the US and so I
think they're they're really two
different approaches to that and I think
it's hard to do everything just like
it's hard to do seed a BCG and growth
like it yeah I think so you I would
encourage you and to always look for a
firm that's focused kind of on what you
are doing right at that point in time ah
yes um how do you like to be approached
by entrepreneurs with you ideas and one
of the biggest mistakes you see
entrepreneurs make when they approach
you with those things yeah i mean the
biggest mistake is somebody coming to me
with the company that like a gaming
company right i don't i don't let I'm
like gamer right and there are a lot of
you and that's the reason is the mistake
is there so many VC as it are right if
you're picking me to come to run that by
it's just I just
Wow okay it's a couple of things either
you talk to a lot of people and you just
keep going or or they're just the
homework wasn't done right so so that's
one thing the way I like to see it done
I mean the best the best way is to find
a common common point to learn something
about me or in the best best way is to
find somebody I know to introduce you
right I even had a rule when I was
hiring at next card if somebody did that
worked in our organization did not know
that person personally I wouldn't hire
them because i thought you know the
valley is so small that if you can't
find that connection point there is a
problem and my only hires it were ever
problematic where when i deviated from
that rule right so so I think you know
it's a pretty small ecosystem out here
and we have linked it I mean these
things that we can have we have linked
in and you know god knows what I mean
you can find somebody that knows knows
me right and figure out how to have a
firm that so and ask for advice don't
tell me your money raising money yeah
yes so much more time to be I'd like to
more questions may be anything okay oh
go ahead what are some sectors that we
think are ripe for disruption and on the
flip side would have some sector
sightseeing car overheated are
overheated um so what what are sectors
that are ripe for disruption and what
are what is overheated right now there's
a lot of heat overall I would say at
this point in time right um but you know
I think lending is definitely over
heated right now so you know with
lending club success and a couple other
companies that have gone out you're
seeing just I mean every other day
there's it there's a new you know
lending company or mortgage marketplace
or something like that right so
definitely those are those are
overheated not to say there will be more
winners there but it's really hard to
tell you know who's going to win and and
what happens when they get overheated is
that they're all fighting over the same
customer your store customer acquisition
cost goes to the roof and then it's just
really hard to win in terms of areas
that are interesting and you know
there's we continue to infant tech for
example we continue to look
you know the insurance markets both here
in Europe we look at what else are we
looking for you know the the business
lending factory and you know accounts
receivable there's a lot happening there
right now that it's beginning to get a
little bit noisy as well and so so when
that starts happening that's when you
really kind of start looking outside you
know you start thinking okay well what's
the next piece is right what is next and
it's funny because in 09 when we did we
needed practice Fusion there were very
few other VCS doing anything in
healthcare IT I actually had a couple of
VCS pull me aside and say wow if you
want to have a really short career in
venture invest in healthcare IT cuz
here's all the bodies you know that have
gone before you and but and so that in
09 that was complete white space right
nobody was doing that and it seemed very
bizarre to sort of think of it but there
were a few things changing right they
had the HITECH Act and the Affordable
Care Act that rolled in a no nine and
twenty ten and but when practice Fusion
went to raise their series b it was
really scary because my list of who
might possibly work at that company it
was like three people want right so we
actually started a whole conference for
them we called it DC to DC we brought
out in each Oprah who was a u.s. CTO at
the time and Todd Park he was ahead of
HHS and invited every VC firm we could
think of right that may possibly be
interested in a healthcare IT and then
partner with Ben rock to do that and
then put because venrock was really that
they've always done healthcare IT right
they're very good at it and but they
were kind of kind of it and then we
brought some corporates and then some
startups and had a little conference
around it and and got practice funded
with the series b but that was hard and
now you look at it and there were no no
hi no healthcare incubators in 2010 that
you know of i think there's like 1,300
now around the world you know if you
just fast forward a few years so things
can overheat it pretty hot and I don't
know right that next thing you were
doing a lot of you know searching on
what that could be I think there's a I
think it's early innings in mobile and
business still mobile enterprise very
early onions there's a lot of
opportunity
there and and there's there's always
opportunities i think in financial
services in every single cycle there are
multiple you know big financial services
opportunities created so and health arm
will say thank you yeah thank you
you